how is this right now i mean this is my
first time interviewing somebody uh face
to face in two years what's it like
being on the road
touring after everything we've gone
through
it's bizarre for sure i mean i
definitely don't feel like i'm on tour
it's been three weeks so i'm like this
is a very fun imaginary game i've been
playing um
but
it's very special i mean i think before
i was touring and touring and touring
and i um didn't even have my debut album
out yet and i just kind of was like oh
my god like
life is so weird and now i'm just like
this is incredible i'm so grateful that
i get to see people and um
yeah it's like i'm kind of
re-introducing myself to
life again so before everything happened
before we all had to shut down
the energy that you get from being on a
stage the energy that you get from a
crowd that is something that people have
tried to replicate or replace when
they're not on a stage where did you go
looking for that energy when you
couldn't be on a stage
to be honest we kind of
said no to a lot of those those like uh
virtual concert things because it's just
not the same and i i had hoped that
things would go back to normal over time
and obviously we're far from normal now
and i don't think we'll ever be normal
again but um i was like no thanks like
i'll just wait until i see them again
because
um yeah i was just busy working on on
music and i wanted to just
prioritize making good music rather than
trying to give them something that i
think we all felt very disappointed and
not being able to experience live music
how used to your stuff did you get and
how difficult was it to finally start
packing for a tour
i didn't say goodbye to a lot of your
stuff for a long time you had it all
yes the weird thing is
um this is the first time in my adult
life that
when i was leaving for tour i was
leaving something behind because i
really was like i'd built my life for
two years and had made new friends and
kind of gotten into a routine and it was
interesting because it was the first
time i felt better like bittersweet
about leaving for a tour i was like oh
like i'm gonna miss my friends that i
didn't have before like i had no friends
before and now i have two like it was
really exciting to be able to miss
something and so
um yeah i got very used to my life but
i'm very happy to leave it behind
because i was getting sick of it i was
like oh god yeah my stuff i have so much
when you're young i mean you are young
but when you're young young young and
you start wanting to do this for a
living
the the the words world tour you sort of
like kick around in your head when
you're that's a dream right like that's
one of those things that you want to be
able to say goodbye to everybody you
know guess where i'm going world tour
what is it like to actually sort of live
that
i mean it's
bizarre it is a dream definitely um but
it's a dream in the sense of like just
simply surreal like yeah i don't think
i'll ever wake up and be like i'm on
tour you should though man
i definitely don't think of life that
way um i'm mostly just like stunned and
my friends are like why why does anyone
care that you exist and i'm like i don't
know i don't know either um i think
that's the fun of it is letting myself
really just take in how
completely ridiculous this is let's talk
about jigsaw where was your head out
where was your heart at what's the story
behind this song jigsaw is a song that i
wrote just for myself like a venting
song um about being insecure and i never
talk about being insecure i'm the kind
of person that's very much like when i
feel bad i'm like oh yeah like i'm great
look at me i'm awesome like i feel
perfectly fine
um and so i was pretty scared to release
it i think it came from
a space of just like there's people in
your life who really make you feel like
you're so
undeserving of love and make you feel
like you have to be something in order
to be
worth something and i wanted to write a
song to kind of remind people like hey
you as you are is great
perfect yeah you can sit down and write
that and be vulnerable
and write a great song alone and you can
feel great afterwards but what's the
feeling of having done it and then you
realize that now you have to share it
it's a terrifying feeling um i think
with my debut with kid crow i didn't
have that thought because i'd really not
released much music so i was like oh
yeah whatever like i'll say whatever i
want to say yeah and now i'm like
i really am going to say so much more
than i said on my debut and it was a
terrifying thought and i was mortified
to release songs there were so many
songs that i was like no like it's just
not very good like don't put it on the
album guys like it's whatever like it's
not good just don't put it on um and
they're like no you you have to put this
out i'm like no it's fine um
so i think um it was a arduous process
um
i definitely think of this past album
making process have been like scraping
my ribs for information instead of
my first album was just like me saying
hello you know
heartache heartbreak insecurity we know
that throughout the history of art those
things have led to some fantastic
pieces of art do you ever find that you
sort of move towards
things that maybe aren't the best for
you thinking that there might be
something great at the end of it
yes my
uh me and my friend's
new motto is
it's good for the plot there you go
sometimes we'll like text each other be
like hey like should i see this person
and they're like probably not but
just it's good for the plot like i think
um it's important to make mistakes and i
very much was
a very cautious child and i'm still very
cautious and i've kind of had to retrain
myself to like
allow myself to be heartbroken because i
think it's more worthwhile to feel
emotions that are terrible than feel
nothing at all
which is something i learned from my
youth of just being like terrified to to
do anything do the people who have
broken your heart when they listen to
your music know that they're the ones
who broke your heart
yes for sure they definitely do and a
lot of people who
just assume that the songs are about
them i'm like you wish no
um yeah a lot of uh people conspiring
about
what is about what um but the people the
people who the songs were actually
written about they know do you tell them
ahead of time no no i just let them find
out wow like whatever it did me wrong
did me wrong
and so when you write something that is
so personal and then you do a show and
you see how that song means not only
something to but also something
different to the people in the audience
does it change the way you look at a
song
i mean nothing is more therapeutic
than writing this like miserable
personal song and then
singing it on tour for months of your
life to like screaming screaming smiling
faces um it really changes the way you
think of that experience and so i think
of like heather and how that song was
like the most personal personal
miserable song to write and now every
night it's the most fun and i'm like
wish i were heather like super fun and
it's um it's a very therapeutic thing
and it does change over time for sure
what is it like being at this stage of
your career and having a friend like
olivia rodrigo i mean so important it's
such a confusing
thing um and very exciting and it's just
nice to have people that you can relate
to um so when you
see when you see somebody because i
don't even know her but watching what
happened to her last january when that
track came out and it shook the world
she went global like that um having seen
the way she handled it did it change the
way you sort of deal with being famous
i mean i think that
she is just so talented and was able to
really kind of um
take this great
burden on her shoulders and she's very
very smart and it's nice to just have
people that you can kind of talk to
about these kinds of things and um
i mean regardless of of who you are i
think being young is confusing and um
it's nice to have friends have you ever
sung together
we sing together like in the car is
there is there anything on anyone's
phone
that if you guys were to release it to
spotify it would crush no no
will there ever be
are you good at being famous
um
you know what i mean by that some people
are real bad at it i don't think it was
ever my intention to to be a singer and
so um i kind of am oblivious to it all
you are
is that uh deliberate do you think
maybe i think it's um important for me
to
stay naive yeah to it all because it is
special and it's something i just have
to remind myself all the time and uh
coachella um how pumped are you for this
i mean so excited it's
weird
it's gonna be very strange but i'm very
what's strange about it
i mean i i went to it a few years ago to
be like wow fun case musgraves like
um so it's gonna be very special to play
it um just a few years later was that
one of those things of where you walked
into that sort of venue and were like
i'm going to be there no i never think
you never thought that no i don't think
that stuff i just think um
i just try to like enjoy each thing that
happens with um
the excitement that i would have if i
were like 12. will you do hoodie
sunglasses coveted masks stand in the
audience and watch the other performers
i'll definitely watch the other before
yeah i'm definitely like dancing
harry
who do you listen to like what is your
sort of routine
um i listen to a lot of music that i
listened to like when i was 10.
um
like i don't know like
early 2010 pop and like like lord and i
listened to like all the kind of like
ridiculous pop music that we were like
that was drilled into our brains as a
kid and i listened to a bunch of random
stuff like country music i grew up in
texas so yeah gotta listen to country
music and um a bunch of random things
yeah who in your life is uh most proud
of you right now probably my best friend
yeah yeah my best friend ashley back
home in texas we've been best friends
since
the sixth grade and even though she
doesn't say it i like to think she's
proud of me is this sort of when you are
so close as you are with ashley was this
sort of like a shared dream between the
two of you where she sort of feels like
she's living it a little too
no we we never had any dreams of this
like i was writing songs in my bedroom
just because i liked it and i didn't
have any
idea of how anything could ever happen
to to dream of it would have been
foolish and it happened
completely unexpected to me
you